I believe that self-love is very
important if you read my work you know
I'm always talking about loving oneself
I never trust anybody who tells me he or
she loves me if the person doesn't love
herself or himself there's an African
saying which is be careful when a naked
person offers you a shirt
I mean if he had some they cover himself
first right so I like to look at self
love it is very important that it comes
from within that you have a sense of
yourself so that when you walk into an
office
you don't go alone bring your people
with you bring everybody who has loved
you with you say grandma come on let's
go
great grandpa you've been dead all this
time to Melissa I have to go in here and
have an interview come on auntie come on
my friends come let's go and when you
walk in people don't know what it is
about you they can't take their eyes off
you you may not be cute in the given
sense you may not be dashing model size
in that particular sense you may not be
any of those things but they can't take
their eyes off you and they say of you
in this incredible wave which I don't
understand they say I don't know but she
has charisma you know what you have is
all those people around you so think of
that any time you have anything to do
bring everybody with you that you can
remember who has loved you and then you
have that sense of having been paid for
and when you walk in people will say now
I think you're overqualified if you
don't laugh you will die you know you
really must laugh and if every human
being in the world would admit it he or
she is the funniest person you've ever
met ever I mean some people just rather
be a little starchy and boring and you
know but the truth is they themselves
know that they are very funny and the
sense of humor is and in self-defense
against those who have pretend not to
have any sense of humor and against the
the cruelties of life when unless laughs
you just watched two amazing clips to
Maya Angelou take the next three minutes
to sit quietly and think about how you
can apply them to your business and your
life believe
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you